Luna wrote in saying hey David are there
particular manners are habits that make
an impression on you when people either
do or don't do them yeah I sort of
mentioned this last week uh in another
audience question when people are rude
to wait staff at restaurants that makes
an insanely negative impression on me
when people just like don't treat wait
staff well at restaurants I immediately
lose respect for you yeah I think there
are more customs and courtesies that are
kind of going out the window now for
example people putting their elbows on
the table that never really seemed to
bother me and you know and some of my
going out of fashion there's some uh
specific table manners things that I
think are sort of relevant in the sense
that they are still in fine dining often
things to pay attention to but that
sometimes get carried too far and I told
the story of a friend of mine who once
was at a dinner a white tablecloth
dinner and spilled some red wine and
when you spill even a drop of red wine
on a tablecloth you can imagine how it
just starts to spread so he took his
napkin that was on his lap and put it on
the table to sort of DAB the red wine
and to prevent the spread from
continuing and his girlfriend at the
time was apparently furious with him
because it's so rude to do anything but
putting your napkin on your lap until
the meal has completely concluded which
it hadn't at that time and I thought
that that was such an unnecessary you
know adherence to an arbitrary rule of
etiquette the guy was just trying to
prevent this huge basketball-sized
circle of red wine from developing on
the table to focus so much on that seems
to me really archaic an antiquated do I
won't have the most etiquette in the
room here do I want to solve the problem
at hand yeah and he clearly he went for
solving the problem at hand okay other
manners or habits that make an
impression on me I think that for me I'm
generally polite to everybody so
politeness usually is my default and it
makes less of an impression on me than
people who are not polite so like when
I'm walking three feet behind someone
and they don't hold the door slightly so
that it just closes on me or right in
front of me as I'm about to walk through
a doorway
I noticed that someone holding the door
for me that's what I do for everyone so
I don't notice that as much I don't know
if you find the same thing where you're
noticing lack of manners more than
politeness and manners yeah I always go
with the holding the door thing but it
can be kind of tricky because what if
they're in that space that's just far
enough that you won't really wait too
long to hold the door open for him so I
will admit that there are times when I'm
walking in front of someone and I'm
definitely sort of in the range where I
might if I slowed down a lot be in the
range to reasonably hold the door for
them but it would start to get a little
awkward because they're still kinda far
behind me what I'll usually do in those
situations and I don't know if this
makes me a bad person I'll stall speed
up and speed walk up such that when i
get to the door it's much more distance
between us and it's way more reasonable
not to hold the door and this has
nothing to do with not wanting to hold
the door it's the idea that if i open
the door when they're 80 feet away and
just stand there holding a door it would
be very strange yet not about being rude
is just there just about avoiding
awkwardness there's actually another one
if you're walking down a street and
there's a man and a woman the man is
supposed to stand and towards the cars
more yet beyond the side of the road
that's a little bit towards the car to
protect the woman yes protect the woman
and i think this dates back to uh horse
and carriage days where where feces from
the horses would splatter all across the
woman you know i don't think that one
necessarily has to be observed anymore
yeah I i I've heard mixed things about
that I've people who tell me you know
that's something men should still do
there's other people who say you know it
it's almost sexist to say the man has to
be walking closer to the cars in the
woman the truth is if a car goes up on
the curb I guess it's slightly more
likely to hit you if you're 12 inches
closer to the curb but it could really
run either person over and then there's
other people who say no it's just polite
in clayton cases a splash of water not
necessarily horse feces but just water
that might be in the you know sort of
like right on the edge of the curb on a
rainy day type of thing uh yeah i don't
know i'm kinda mixed on that one I all I
guess I'll continue to do it you're
gonna keep doing ya I'm gonna do it
alright well Pat sign pad up he's going
to continue doing that send me your
thoughts if there are other manners or
lack thereof that make a particular
impression on you thanks for your
audience questions great bonus show
coming
up today and also the indy gogo
fundraiser continues please check it out
even if he could don't can only donate a
few dollars check out david pakman.com
slash donate and donate what you can